what's going on guys this is rob and uh
first things first right this it's
monday so it's our weekly video of we
need to talk about such and such and in
this video we're going to talk about
herogasm
moms and dads aunts and uncles grandmas
and grandpas adults out there who happen
to be hearing this right now
do not let your kids watch this video
because this is not for the kitties
right so here's the thing
you guys are not ready for hero gasoline
because look let me let me tell you
something man i've been reading comics
for almost 30 years at this point right
for a long time i started reading them
when i was 11 years old i'm 39 years old
now it's been almost almost 30 years
that i've been i've been reading comic
books from all different manner of
writers and and people from across the
industry i once read a story called
marvel ruins which is probably one of
the darkest stories that i've ever read
like imagine a marvel universe where
everything bad that can happen does
happen and that's
marvel ruins it had nothing on herogasm
with everything that i've read
the herogasm story arc even to me it was
just shocking stuff it was like wow i
mean
jesus like just the most depraved things
right so here's the deal behind this
right uh when it comes to the hirogasm
story arc this is one of those turning
point story arcs and of course over at
comics explained i've got the whole hero
gasm story arc there i've got the whole
boys run if you're interested you can
watch the herogasm video just be aware
it might be a little hard to follow in
terms of the the interpersonal story
arcs involving like huey and you know
mother's milk and billy butcher and the
female and all that because it all kind
of builds up to it but it'll give you a
general gist of what to expect regarding
the hero gasms story and you can just
adapt the tv show to what you're seeing
in the in the video but the thing about
this is that um when when this happens
as you guys know from the tv show by the
way this may have spoilers as you guys
know from the tv show homelander is
growing more and more unstable right
he's going more and more crazy it was
very much the same way in the comics
that he was just going more and more
insane hirogasm is when everything
changed right when everything just
shifted because you're probably asking
yourself the question with all this
instability that homelanders displaying
here where's it all leading to right
what's like the big thing that happens
that's that happens in herogasm right so
the way this works and it's kind of a
nuts thing right the way this works is
like the seven and like homeland and all
those guys they all call together like
this big press conference right so like
every major news outlet is there and
they're like oh there's some big alien
invasion coming you know or and it's
always something like that right it's an
annual thing vaude american does this
every single year if for no other reason
than to help all the superheroes blow
off steam but it's always like some big
thing some crisis some alien invasion
some you know potentially world ending
calamity and they've got to take off
like all the superheroes have to band
together and they got to take off and
face that threat and they'll be gone for
a few days but rest assured everybody
right the day's going to be safe that's
how they they market the whole thing so
the general public being none the wiser
right just celebrates and it's like yeah
go save our lives you know that kind of
a thing and so when that happens every
vaude american-backed superhero and i
say that because one of the things i
hope they explore in the show is that
not every single superhero that exists
out there is backed by vod american you
kind of see it a little bit with soldier
boy in the show but i mean the ones who
have compound v but have nothing to do
with vod american that are like they
don't want to have anything to do with
them like that one guy who was based out
of russia i'm hoping they give us that
i'm also hoping they give us the oh my
god what was that group called the
glorious seven year plan i hope they
give us that that team was amazing
that russian guy with a huge dude that
whole story was just hilarious so here's
the thing right so so all the vaude
american back superheroes they all go
off to this private island that's owned
by vaude american and vaught flies in
like sex workers in the whole nine yards
right paying them like a hundred grand a
pop and basically for that whole weekend
anything goes everything goes there are
no rules think of it as like the purge
except it's all just sexual depravity
that's really all it is for the whole
weekend now here's where things get
really really interesting because that
in and of itself is shocking enough and
you're gonna see some mind-blowing stuff
one of the things the writers said for
the show is that there is not going to
be a homelander and soldier boy thing so
sorry for all you guys out there who are
writing fan fiction about that kind of
stuff you're not going to see it but the
thing about this is that you you have
like what is it a group called
fantastico so it's basically like the
fantastic four none of which are related
i don't believe but basically like all
the guys are just running a train on
what's essentially the invisible woman
right i mean it's just it's crazy stuff
right i mean and that's the thing these
women sign up for it right like a
hundred grand like they just they they
sacrifice it all and they get pushed to
the limits i mean it's absolutely nuts
right like imagine a person who's like
the incredible hulk just railing into
you right that's basically what hirogasm
is just some average girl right just
herogasm so the thing about this is in
the background of that the boys are
there to basically figure out what in
the world's going on gain information
different things along those lines and
so there are some elements in the comics
that don't necessarily apply to the show
like for example one of the things you
learn is that during the events of 9 11
that what vaude american had previously
done is they had essentially
had the former ceo of vaude american vic
the veep he basically became the vice
president of the united states right
victor newman he ended up becoming
called victovie because you know he was
the vice president one of the funny
things garth ennis modeled him after
george w bush right so a simpleton who
just does what he's told but the thing
about this is you end up learning that
victor newman who of course is basically
portrayed by victoria newman now so
things were a little bit different in
terms of the tv show but victor newman
in the comics was the vice president of
the united states who had quite
literally neutralized dakota bob the
president of the united states during 9
11. this was done at the behest of vaude
american so that what vod could do is
they could send the seven in and the
seven could basically quote unquote save
the day the whole thing went belly up
right it was all just botched they ended
up flying or the plane into everything
went nuts the plane flew into the
brooklyn bridge killed a thousand people
it was the worst case scenario vladimir
can swept it all under the rug but the
whole thing was that if that had worked
it would have led to bought american
basically becoming the sole supplier of
of superhumans in the military
industrial complex which has always been
the main goal of all-american or at
least one of their main goals it's what
they've always been shooting for and so
as a result of that it's just that
that's just one of the things that goes
on now victor newman does end up getting
his his just rewards which will probably
happen to vic victoria newman i don't
think it'll happen the same way it did
in the comics
[Laughter]
in the comics homelander ripped off that
well okay
do we do do i you know what let's i'll
do a different video here's what happens
to homelander in the in the comics right
i'll do that as a separate video because
i don't want to spoil the ending for you
guys we're just talking about your
orgasm the whole thing about this though
is that you basically end up getting
this scenario where you have all these
revelations that come out right one of
the things that takes place is that
while the boys and everybody are there
huey is actually violated by black noir
so it's really kind of crazy some of
that stuff that goes down but the big
revelation right the big thing that
happens during herogasm and this is
really going to be the big takeaway from
the herogasm arc in the boys which as
far as i can tell is likely where it'll
end because it was one hell of a
cliffhanger in the comic that the way it
played out is homelander had basically
banded together a ton of the superheroes
and essentially said like why are we
serving vaude american like there's no
reason for us to serve what american
like we can just conquer everything i
mean who's gonna stop us
like no one's gonna be able to stop us
right we're the ones who stop the bad
guys so what happens when we become the
bad guys that's one of the things that
goes on right that's that's the thing
that happens so literally he bans all
the different superheroes together and
then orchestrates an attack to
effectively conquer the united states
now whether or not it works and how that
whole thing transpires i won't reveal
here but it is a really really cool
concept because what you're seeing in
the show is it basically building up to
that and there's been little tidbits
right when you had that that just
amazing moment when you had homelander
talking to starlight and literally she
was talking about how she was just gonna
dump the airplane footage and he just
gets really sinister and really dark
really fast he's like you know what go
for it right what's the worst that
happens i lose my popularity i'm kicked
off the seven you know and goes over all
these things that he would lose and he
says i mean it's true i would lose
everything but then like in one of the
just most amazing moments he looks at
her and probably the most dangerous face
i've ever seen him have and he simply
said but then i would become a man with
nothing to lose and then what do you
think would happen then right like it
was just terrifying but it's it's just
like you see that moment there right you
see these little moments where he's kind
of going crazy he's obviously getting
fed up by bought american he's the one
that basically runs it now right like
john carlo esposito's out of the picture
so he's effectively running vaughn you
know all these little these little you
know character character story arcs and
so on for homelander all really lead to
him just launching a major campaign so
it's a really really cool thing right
that's kind of the big thing to come out
of the herogasm story arc but all in all
it's an amazing story right and there's
other stuff that goes on too there's
some other revelations that take place
here but the reality is that those are
really the big ones right those are the
huge ones but for what you can expect
from herogasm on the boys series that's
where things get a little murky because
the reality here is that the comic of
herogasm was really just borderlined
adults material and like you get what
i'm saying here like it was borderline
like you could even make a credible
argument it was kind of pornographic in
nature right just in terms of how it was
done even for an amazon netflix i'm
sorry an amazon tv series it would
really stretch the limits of what they
could get away with i mean if herogasm
the you know depending on how they
handle it if that will do anything on
the boys it'll really ask us the
question on a societal level how much
can you actually get away with when it
comes to streaming services right like
are we going back to the days of the
spice channel right channel 57 back in
lexington kentucky or are we not
necessarily going that route and just
doing things in kind of a an extreme
manner but still a little bit toned down
we won't really know until the show
comes out but regardless of how they do
it if it's even anything remotely close
to the herogasm series from the boys
right that miniseries it's gonna be
shocking and you're just gonna kind of
be like wow this is absolutely insane
right but again it all kind of depends
on on how the whole thing goes down so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace